all right let's continue with our tour
of what was just
an incredible incredible weekend and i
have something for you that is not just
amazing it's also really smart
south carolina republican senator
lindsey graham we don't like lindsay
he has a serious challenger this year
it's democrat jamie harrison and the
polling
looks like this really could be a fight
i'll tell you that in a moment
lindsey graham also aside from being a
horrible senator has
all sorts of possible coronavirus
exposure especially now that tons of
people at the white house and around
trump
have the virus so there was a debate
over the weekend lindsey graham versus
jamie harrison and jamie harrison
brought
his own plexiglas barrier to put around
himself to protect him from lindsey
graham's germs this is the perfect
combination
of being hilarious from like a visual
optics perspective
but also completely reasonable given the
irresponsibility of the republican party
and the fact that the virus is spreading
like wildfire
among republicans who were close to
donald trump chris christie has tested
positive
kellyanne conway has tested positive and
on and on
lindsey graham recently had contact with
republican senator mike lee
mike lee has tested positive and was at
that amy coney barrett
super spreader event in the white house
last saturday and so
uh he jamie harrison bringing his own
plexiglas
and that actually came up during the
debate check this out here's jamie
harrison
not judge barrett not the supreme court
you know
this has impacted me personally judy my
uh grand aunt gladys passed away this
july
in a nursing home by herself that is the
story that so many americans are
experiencing
right now and part of why we're
experiencing no we're not going to blame
the president we shouldn't blame the
president we shouldn't blame anybody
for the the inception of this disease
but where blame should come
is how we handle this disease
whether or not we take it seriously you
know tonight i am taking it seriously
that's why i put this
plexiglass up because you know it's not
just about me
it's about the people in my life that i
have to take care of as well my two boys
my wife my grandmother
this debate was truly
a brutal drubbing by jamie harrison of
lindsey graham
and it's south carolina lindsey graham
may well get reelected
but one of the best moments for jamie
harrison
and the worst for lindsey graham was
when jamie
harrison went after lindsay aggressively
for being
a complete and total hypocrite on the
supreme court nomination of amy coney
barrett remember that lindsey graham
back in 2016
when they held off uh and suppressed and
obstructed the nomination of merit
garland lindsey graham said hold me to
it
even if this happens with trump we're
not doing it in the last year
and then now lindsey graham says amy
coney barrett yeah let's do it uh jamie
harrison calls him out and it's great
it reminds me of playing monopoly with
my son you change the rules that
he changes the rules every time he gets
you know senator you said
use my words against me and you said it
after the kavanaugh meetings not before
the kavanaugh hearings
after the kavanaugh hearings and your
words your promise was
that no uh judicial nominee should be
considered or approved or what have you
in the last
year of an election and you even named
president trump when you said it
and so this is my thing you know my
grandfather always taught me he said
jamie a man is only
as good as his word well senator how
good is your word when you made a
promise to the american people
and even more you made a promise to the
folks in south carolina that you
wouldn't be doing what you're doing
right now
and of course jamie harrison is 100
correct lindsey graham is a huge
hypocrite on this the
republicans haven't shown that they care
about hypocrisy but lindsay is a massive
hypocrite and it's just
a really bad performance by lindsey
graham he seemed
rattled throughout a really funny moment
lindsey graham
seems perplexed here he seems visually
visibly perplexed about
where is the money coming from who are
these people donating money
to jamie harrison he simply can't
conceive of the idea
that a lot of people even in south
carolina just don't like him he thinks
it's some kind of democratic
conspiracy it's like no when people
don't like you
and they know you they often donate to
your opponent that's
it it was about ads and money
let's talk about money in politics where
the hell is all this money coming from
what is it about south carolina's
attracted almost 100 million dollars
into uh jamie harris and mr harrison's
coffers
they hate me this is not about mr
harrison this is about liberals hating
my guts
because i stood up for kavanaugh when
they tried to destroy his life
this is about me helping donald trump
the only good republican is one that
tries to
undercut trump i lost to president trump
when i ran for president if you don't
remember me running for president it's
not your fault
didn't last that long that is completely
right
it was crazy when lindsey graham went on
that lunatic rant defending brett
kavanaugh people don't like him because
of it many people
it has been ridiculous to watch lindsey
graham defend
anything that donald trump does while
always trying to pretend that he's
one of the reasonable republicans now
there is a real opportunity here for
lindsey graham to be defeated
the entire point of this segment is to
remind you
there is an alternative to lindsey
graham in south carolina
yes jamie harrison is not the most
progressive of progressive democrats
yes he's been a south carolina
democratic party
insider for a while but we're talking
about removing
lindsey graham here and possibly taking
the senate
which would lead to actually getting
things done
if indeed joe biden is able to defeat
donald trump the latest polls out of
south carolina
you will notice we have polls from the
last six seven months or even more up on
the screen you'll notice this was not a
close race early the
in the year uh lindsey graham was up 13
and 17
in february but by july lindsey graham
was only up
by seven but the last four polls in this
race from august
and september are three ties and lindsey
graham ahead by
only one this is south carolina
my friends and a democratic challenger
could defeat a long-time incumbent
republican senator if you're looking at
a race to get involved in
phone banking or in other ways this is a
beautiful race
and uh when we talk about you know
trump's not looking great in georgia
trump's not looking great in texas but
he'll he'll still win
but he may have to fight for it this is
one where
it really could just be a win for
democrats it's not just the benefit of
lindsay will have to spend money
defending his seat
that's great but we could actually go
for a win here we should do it
it could be the seat any one of these
close races could be the seat
that flips the senate to democrats
and this is one i would recommend you
get involved in
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire
book on your way home from work they
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video